[Musique]
gaby et bénévole auprès des sans abri de
miami ce soir elle cherche l'un d'entre
eux en particulier un certain gordon
salle où tu as vu gordon je le cherche
elle le connaît bien et elle pense
qu'elle va pouvoir le sortir de la rue
durablement et d'une façon très simple
c'est bon qu'on a donné ce dont tu avais
besoin où il ça va allez merci il est là
celui qu'elle est venue chercher
gordon un ancien chef de chantier
malades sans abri depuis 20 ans il vient
enfin d'accepter ce qu'elle lui propose
depuis des mois on a souvent parlé
ensemble de retrouver sa famille et il
n'a jamais valu aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il est prêt
pourquoi aujourd'hui parce qu'il a fait
un avc et sa marque un changement
ouais tu l'a échappé belle et comment
dire ça redonne du sens à la vie ça
donne envie de se rapprocher
vous avez perdu votre travail oui à
cause de problèmes physiques je ne
pouvais plus exercer
en vieillissant j'ai eu des problèmes de
hanches et je me suis cassé le dos
j'ai fait une dépression car la douleur
ne me quittait pas et rien ne parvenez à
l'arrêter alors je me suis mis à boire
et forcément ça n'a rien arrangé
gaby commence son enquête elle ravive
ses souvenirs pour trouver un point de
départ
parle-moi de ce que tu aimes tu m'as dit
que tu n'avais plus famille
mes parents sont morts j'ai deux soeurs
mais je ne connais pas leur nom de femme
mariée ni où elle habite et tu te
souviens de leur date de naissance
je crois qu'elles sont de 1965
donc elles sont plus jeune que toi oui
elles ont 50 morts
ensuite elle enregistre une courte vidéo
qu'elle va poster sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur une toute nouvelle
application qui commence à faire des
miracles
ok allons-y addressed au téléphone comme
si tu parles a été seul
salut mes soeurs
je sais que ça peut paraître étrange car
ça fait très longtemps
la moitié d'une vie mais j'espère que
toutes les deux vous portez bien je sais
que vous avez des enfants et tout ça et
j'espère que tout va bien pour vous
ce message trouvera peut-être son
destinataire
ok on va soumettre ton dossier là c'est
en train de charger et ça va être donné
un détective qui va essayer de recoller
tous ces petits morceaux
merci chers gaby
[Musique]
pour cela gaby va mobiliser toute une
équipe d'enquêteurs
gordon à 59 ans et sa santé décline
l'espérance de vie d'un sans abri et de
50 ans dans la rue lui trouver un toit
devient vital
gaby va-t-elle parvenir à délivrer ce
message aux soeurs de gordon
[Musique]
se voit la semaine prochaine au caire et
si tu veux me voir avant sache que je
suis toujours dans le coin ok ok
t'inquiète pas pour moi ça va aller
merci pour tout gaby je t'aime fort
fais attention à toi passez une bonne
nuit
gordon va-t-il retrouver une famille un
toit après vingt ans passés dans la rue
c'est le début d'une longue chaîne de
solidarité qui va se mettre en place à
travers le pays est mobilisé des
dizaines de personnes des bénévoles pour
la plupart
[Musique]
tout a commencé à san francisco
grâce à cet homme
qui vit nadler a inventé le concept de
la vidéo qui fait des miracles
[Musique]
salut tu veux une paire de chaussettes
oui merci t'en prie
à 34 ans cet humaniste expert en
nouvelles technologies à créer une start
up qui vient en aide gratuitement aux
sans abri pour retrouver un toit grâce à
leurs familles
le pays connaît une crise sans précédent
chaque année trois millions et demi
d'américains past une nuit dehors
un quart vite ici en californie dans des
camps qualifié par les nations unies de
taudis aux conditions de vie inhumaines
on peut tourner à n'importe quel
carrefour on trouvera des centaines de
gens qui vivent dans la rue
on est à san francisco dans l'un des
endroits les plus riches au monde mais
c'est aussi là où il ya la plus forte
concentration de pauvreté de sans abri
aux états unis
en cause le prix des loyers
3000 euros pour un studio à san
francisco mais aussi les aléas
climatiques
incendies en californie
inondations au texas ouragans floride
des milliers de personnes sont à la rue
aux états unis il manque aujourd'hui 7
millions de logements pour les plus
démunis
[Musique]
en tant qu'être humain
chaîne geo je ne peux pas imaginer
passer à côté ne rien faire alors que ce
qu'on va être mon frère mon père mon
fils
ou un ami
il y a cinq ans kevin a eu l'idée de me
réclamer cette cheese littéralement
message miraculeux il utilise la
puissance des réseaux sociaux pour
toucher des millions de personnes et
retrouver ainsi les familles des sans
abri même avec très peu d'indicés
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un que vous
souhaitez retrouver
voilà ma carte vous m'appeler sur mon
portable à n'importe quelle heure et on
vous aidera à reprendre contact avec
quelqu'un de votre famille ça peut être
votre fils votre frère votre père qui
vous voulez il ya quelqu'un qui vous
souhaitez parler
les employés de merkel mais cette gisent
honteux aussi connu la rue
beverly a passé 18 ans son domicile ici
même à san francisco et c'est
aujourd'hui sa force elle connaît les
mots les peurs sait comment parler
recruté il ya deux ans elle gagne 800
euros par mois
ça me fait du bien de faire ça quand je
le vois je me vois et j'ai envie qu'ils
vivent la même chose j'espère pouvoir
lui dit
jérémy à 45 ans il a passé la moitié de
sa vie dehors
aujourd'hui il aimerait renouer avec son
père kevin tente de le localiser depuis
son téléphone
non c'est quoi d'inde oui mais il ya un
surnom l'appel toc
et laisse moi regardez ce que je trouve
on a un accord spécial avec les anciens
annuaire téléphonique alors je viens de
faire une recherche rapide et je suis
tombé sur cette personne qui habite en
californie je pense que c'est son père
si c'est si facile de retrouver un
proche pourquoi ne sont ils plus en
contact
il y a plein de raisons possibles ça
peut être la honte la gêne la peur ou
d'isolement
il ne maîtrise pas les réseaux sociaux
certains ont perdu les numéros de
téléphone et ne savent pas comment
joindre leur famille
leur portable a été volé ou ils n'ont
pas internet
pour augmenter les chances de réussite
l'équipe propose à jérémiades enregistré
un message qui sera publiée sur le site
de miracle mais ces devises mais aussi
sur les réseaux sociaux
salut je cherche mon père si vous le
retrouver vraiment c'est cool sinon je
ferai avec merci de partager
pourquoi vous pensez que c'est une bonne
chose de revoir votre père je me dis que
ce serait bien qu'ils sachent que je
suis toujours vivant c'est important
dans la vie la famille les liens du sang
reprendre contact ça peut vous aider oui
j'aimerais bien c'est bien ce que fait
cette association
s'est fait du bien d'avoir des personnes
comme ça
ça vous arrive qu'on s'intéresse à votre
histoire comment sont les gens avec vous
oh vous savez en général je montre juste
ma pancarte qu'est ce qu'il y a écrit
dessus
à la recherche de bonté humaine avait
trouvé aujourd'hui ouais je crois bien
pour le moment le père de jeremiah est
injoignable
beverly et kevin vont maintenant remuer
ciel et terre et exploré toutes les
pistes ils veulent apporter une réponse
à cet homme le plus vite possible
je me sens triste j'étais comme ça aussi
et j'avais froid en crever j'étais gelé
là dans la rue aujourd'hui j'ai la
chance de ne plus avoir froid moi j'ai
un bel appartement alors c'est
impossible que je le laisse tomber
je reviendrai le voir lui donner des
nouvelles et lui apporter un café
après plusieurs jours dans quête
l'équipe apprendra que le père de
jeremiah est décédé l'an dernier
mais ce n'est que le début il leur faut
trouver un proche un ancien ami une
connaissance
quelqu'un qui pourrait l'aider
kevin a trouvé des soutiens au coeur de
la silicon valley un grand groupe lui
prête un bureau sorti major de sa
promotion ce diplômé de cambridge au
réputé aimant faire fortune chez un
géant du web mais durant ses études la
perte d'un proche a changé sa vie
[Musique]
mon oncle a passé 30 ans dans la rue il
était schizophrène et souvent on ne
savait pas où il était je me suis
demandé si une personne comme lui avait
pu partager son parcours sa vie ça
m'aurait aidé à mieux comprendre
un jour il m'a dit je me suis sentie sdf
non pas quand j'ai dormi dehors mais
lorsque j'ai perdu contact avec les
familles
tout commence il y a cinq ans
kevin s'adresse à jeffrey un sdf qu'il
croise tous les jours
sans trop réfléchir
il lui propose d'enregistrer un message
sur son téléphone portable
qu'est ce que tu veux dire à ta soeur ou
aux gens de ta ville tu ne les a pas vus
depuis longtemps ils doivent te chercher
oui ça fait si longtemps le temps est
passé à une vitesse je pense que ça doit
faire 21 ans que je ne suis pas rentré à
la maison
je suis allé chez moi ce soir là et j'ai
posté la vidéo sur une page facebook
relié à sa ville d'origine
sous la vidéo j'ai écrit j'ai rencontré
cette personne voilà son histoire
quelques informations sur lui et les
gens qu'il recherche si quelqu'un le
reconnaît faites le moi savoir désolé
pour le dérangement et joyeux noël
en à peine une heure une centaine de
personnes ont commencé à partager cette
vidéo
[Musique]
240 partage des commentaires des miens
et 20 minutes plus tard sa soeur a été
retrouvé
hello jeff c'est ta soeur jennifer juste
pour te dire à quel point on est heureux
d'avoir de tes nouvelles j'ai parlé à
plein de gens ici pour essayer de te
faire revenir à la maison était d une
fois que tu seras là un message pour
tous est celui ci si tu n'abandonne pas
je ne renoncerai pas non plus
ça m'a bouleversé
je ne m'y attendais pas du tout je ne
pensais pas que non seulement les gens
allaient le reconnaître mais en plus
l'aimer autant
il ya des gens qui ont dit j'étais à
l'école avec jeffrey j'ai une boîte de
construction est ce qu'il a besoin d'un
job où je travaille au ministère est ce
qu il a une mutuelle santé
et puis il ya eu plusieurs cagnotte
organisée dans sa ville pour le ramener
à la maison
une ville qui récoltent de l'argent pour
faire revenir un sans abri chez lui
c'est super fort
mir écoles mais cette devise est né ce
jour là depuis la petite entreprise a
sorti durablement de la rue 300
personnes
dont 80 % des cas les familles contacter
répondent positivement
c'est l'incroyable histoire de jasmin et
son oncle wayne
toute la famille le pense est mort lui a
survécu durant vingt ans dans la rue
sans attaches il a connu le pire avec la
drogue l'alcool et la prison mais il ya
deux ans le miracle l'association
retrouve sa nièce qui l'accueille à bras
ouverts et le sort de la rue comme on le
voit sur ces images
[Musique]
c'est incroyable je vous remercie
tellement pour ce que vous avez fait
pour ma famille
ça faisait si longtemps qu'on le
recherchait
mais regarde moi cette barbe
ni oui tu avais une sacrée barbe
aujourd'hui il se voit très souvent
tu as beaucoup changé
je suis fier de lui et heureuse de
savoir qui n'a plus à dormir dehors à
vivre dangereusement
je suis fier aussi de tous les efforts
qu'il a accomplis c'est vraiment un
exemple pour moi
je suis vraiment heureux d'avoir
retrouvé une famille car j'ai passé
tellement d'années tout seul dehors
une fois sorti de la rue j'ai aimé ça
j'ai aimé avoir mon propre appartement
mais je dois faire attention à rester en
dehors des problèmes à respecter la loi
parce que sinon je vais perdre ce
logement donc je me contrôle
guérir de la rue peut prendre du temps
wayne préfère vivre seul alors sa
famille lui paie ce petit appartement à
70 ans il vit sur un fil mais l'équipe
de kevin veille sur lui et
l'accompagnent dans cette réinsertion
voilà là c'est ma cuisine est ici c'est
ma chambre j'ai une télé et le câble
mais je n'ai encore rien installer
vous n'avez pas beaucoup d'affaires
non je ne garde pas grand chose juste au
cas où je dois retourner vivre dans la
rue
toutes mes affaires personnelles doivent
tenir dans un sac à dos
derrière ces retrouvailles c'est tout un
réseau qui s'est mobilisé l'équipe de
kevin compte aujourd'hui cinq salariés
et 1400 volontaire
comment parvient-il à se financer
il n'a pas trouvé de fonds publics mais
des investisseurs privés et pour une
raison étonnante il rend justement
visite à l'une de ces bienfaitrice
bonsoir carrière
comment allez vous
vous êtes 13 pour le rendez vous je suis
ravi de vous voir
karine food gère une des plus grosses
associations de riverains de san
francisco chaque année elle dispose d'un
budget de 6 millions d'euros pour
améliorer la vie du quartier et chaque
année les habitants soutiennent
financièrement l'initiative de kevin
[Musique]
wehrli par exemple on lui demande
d'enregistrer au minimum un à deux
messages à chaque fois qu'elle sort
c'est une obligation de résultat ça
permet de montrer aux résidents qu'on
est présent
ça veut dire que les gens qui vivent ici
cotisent par compassion pour les sans
abri
non ce n'est pas vraiment la raison qui
les pousse à nous financer il donne de
l'argent pour être sûrs que leur
quartier soit propre et sécurisée on ne
peut pas juste les déplacés les sans
abri d'un endroit à un autre mais nous
n'avons pas les structures pour les
accueillir à san francisco même si on
essaie
alors en parallèle on tente d'être
créatif de rester humain et de trouver
des solutions simples pour leur trouver
une maison et un travail
cette année kevin a récolté 100 mille
euros de fonds privés de quoi étendre
son réseau à travers tout le pays c'est
ce qui va permettre peut-être de sauver
gordon le sans abri de miami
la suite de l' enquête sur gordon se
passe à l'autre bout du pays à seattle
nous avons rendez vous avec marc haskins
il a était détective privé durant 30 ans
à la retraite il est devenu bénévole
pour merkel mais c'est gees il a résolu
une centaine de cas en quelques clics
grâce à des accès réservé aux
professionnels de l'enquète
[Musique]
alors gordon a dit qu'il était
originaire de los angeles
la première chose que j'ai faite c'est
d'aller sur une base de données d'état
civil
ça m'a donné toute une série de noms
mais aucun était le bon
donc j'ai essayé de trouver ses soeurs
j'avais leurs deux prénoms
il n'y avait aucune correspondance avec
ce nom de famille dans tous les états
unis
[Musique]
alors j'ai tapé le prénom run qui est
celui de son père et là ça a marché il
n'est pas mort il est dans l'ontario au
canada
les tout de suite appelé et je lui ai
demandé s'il était ok pour revoir son
fils
il m'a répondu sèchement non merci je ne
veux plus avoir affaire à lui mais il
m'a donné les numéros de ses soeurs j'ai
appelé j'ai laissé des messages et c'est
une stéphanie qui m'a répondu en premier
elle était en pleurs totalement
bouleversée elle disait mon dieu mon
dieu
là ça m'a pris peut-être 1h 1h30 de
recherche et c'était fait
pour ça c'est vraiment super
satisfaisant ce genre d' enquête
quand vous avez cette aptitude à
reconnecter les gens ça peut changer
leur destin ça peut changer leur vie
l'avis de gordon va-t-elle changer
quarante huit heures après que mark l'a
contacté nous sommes allés rencontrer
stéphanie
la soeur de gordon vie bien au canada
elle est encore sous le choc de la
nouvelle
elle n'a pas vu son frère depuis 20 ans
il lui reste ses photos qu'elle montera
son fils
tu vois là c'est mon frère en fait c'est
son oncle conclut gordon et là il pose
avec son chien
la dernière fois que je les ai eus au
téléphone c'était juste après leur
mariage ils voulaient me féliciter me
souhaiter bonne chance passer bonjour à
tout le monde c'était son dernier appel
en rupture avec son père
gordon disparaît sans donner
d'explications
stéphanie a alors 35 ans elle mobilise
la police et engage un détective privé
après plusieurs années l'enquêté stopper
stéphanie ignorer que son frère vivait
aux états unis dans la rue
j'ai reçu ce message de marque à skins
il m'a dit je suis détective privé je
travaille pour mieux récolter 7 6 est ce
que vous connaissez un certain gordon
et je ne suis même pas allé au bout du
message je n'ai pas tout lu j'ai juste
littéralement lâché mais à faire mon sac
tout et j'ai tout de suite rappelé
j'ai espéré ce miracle pendant 20 ans et
le voilà
au moins je sais qu'il est vivant
certes pas dans les conditions que
j'aurais souhaité pour lui mais on va
changer c'est bof je l'espère
c'est comme si tout s'était écrasé dans
sa vie et je ne sais pas comment et
personne n'a été là pour l'aider
et c'est ce qui me rend le plus triste
le savoir dehors tout seul
pour établir un premier contact
gaby a demandé à stéphanie d'écrire une
lettre
elle espère remettre ce message à gordon
cher gordon mon frère je te cherche
depuis plus de 20 ans je ne peux
imaginer ton quotidien sans domicile ta
vie dans les rues de miami
sache que tu es le bienvenu ici même
s'il fait très froid il ya une tempête
de neige
j'ai gardé toutes les lettres et les
photos que tu m'as envoyé
j'ai montré mes trois enfants qui est
hongre gordon
j'espère que je te manque autant que tu
me manques et qu'on parviendra à se
retrouver je l'espère très vite
je t'aime a assigné ta soeur stéphanie
stéphanie est prête à offrir un toit à
son frère une famille mais les choses ne
vont pas se passer comme prévu
à miami les nouvelles ne sont pas bonnes
gaby n'a pas croisé gordon depuis
plusieurs maraudes et ça n'était jamais
arrivé
elle n'a même pas pu lui dire que sa
soeur a été retrouvé
ce soir elle espère encore le voir
est ce que quelqu'un a vu gordon
le vieux monsieur oui le vieux monsieur
on le cherche la dernière fois qu'il est
venu ici c'était le mois dernier on ne
l'a pas revu depuis
tous les mardis j'espère le trouver là
j'ai aussi cherché sous les ponts
partout il a l'habitude d'aller mais
rien
si tu le croises tu peux lui dire que
j'aimerais le voir tu sais que quand je
cherche quelqu'un comme ça c'est
toujours pour une bonne nouvelle
gordon est peut-être à l'hôpital mais
sans papiers d'identité
personne n'a pu le confirmer
ou alors at il changé d'avis dans 20 %
des cas le choc des retrouvailles et
insurmontable gaby doit maintenant
l'annoncé à stéphanie
l'an soir stéphanie ça va oui et vous ça
va mais malheureusement ne parvient pas
à trouver gordon
j'espère qu'il a envie de nous revoir
autant que nous
c'est lui qui a fait la démarche pour
vous retrouver le plus dur a été fait il
a repris contact il a expliqué sa
situation
ça a été dur pour lui et ça lui a
demandé beaucoup de courage oui c'est
vrai merci beaucoup on se reparle très
vite ok
on va le retrouver j'en suis sûre et
certaine le message a été délivré à sa
famille
et quand on le trouvera il saura qu'il
est aimé qu'il manque à tout le monde
c'est juste un peu difficile parce que
ça serait dans la tente chaque jour
chaque nuit elle attend encore et encore
ça peut prendre du temps oui ça peut
être long ça demande du temps
d'assimiler leur histoire et qu'ils
acceptent de se livrer
deux semaines plus tard gaby a
finalement retrouvé gordon il était
hospitalisé pour un infarctus à deux
heures de route de miami il a appelé sa
soeur stéphanie un premier contact mais
il ne souhaite pas encore vivre avec
elle
gaby ne perd pas espoir elle sait que
cette décision peut prendre du temps
comme avec john qui grâce à merkel mais
cette gym et gaby s'apprête à rencontrer
son frère qu'il n'a pas vu depuis trente
sept ans
john vit aujourd'hui dans ce motel en
banlieue de miami quand il était encore
sans abri il avait demandé à gaby de
retrouver sa famille puis il avait
disparu pendant deux mois il ya quelques
jours il a repris contact jaune à
trouver du travail et n'est plus à la
rue ça y est ils se sont prêts à revoir
son frère
pourquoi on est là tu sais pourquoi on
est là pour voir mon frère que je n'ai
pas vu depuis trente ans depuis 37 ans
ah oui 37 ans
j'attends que ton frère arrive parce que
je veux voir ça j'ai même pleuré en
venant ici tellement je suis heureuse
pour toi
oui moi aussi j'ai pleuré
c'est mon frère bob ici sur la photo
oui avec sa femme c'est ça c'est celui
là ton frère
john souffre de troubles mentaux comme
la moitié des sans abri rester sans
soins il ne sait plus ce qu'il a fait
tout ce temps ni pourquoi il a disparu
durant la teinte son tram a pu l'être
deux fois par semaine m'envoyer des
messages tous les jours il me disait ah
ouais mon frère là tu retrouvé quand
vais-je le voir il était très angoissée
il a sauté dans un avion et m'a dit
c'est mon frère j'arrive
c'est son frère lors des retrouvailles
un moment rare
salut bab comment savoir mon dieu c'est
bien toi
la dernière fois qu'ils se sont vu john
avait 20 ans ça fait longtemps
[Rires]
entre
john a également une soeur aînée qu'ils
appellent immédiatement
et je suis assis à côté de notre frère
john
john a comment vas tu
vas leur bien il est juste
c'est ça un peu plus vieux c'est vrai
je pense qu'on peut plus faire les mêmes
bêtises que quand on était gamin
je me sens tellement bien c'est comme si
toutes les questions qu'on se posait
depuis 37 ans trouvé enfin leurs
réponses et de la meilleure des façons
l'avenir on va le construire ensemble un
jour après l'autre ça va demander de la
patience de la confiance mais ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'on ne va plus te perdre
pendant 37
tiens regarde ça c'est ma fille kristen
ces gens change des vies et je serai
reconnaissant envers eux pour l'éternité
si quelqu'un vous appelle de la part
d'american mcgee's s'il vous plaît
répondez prenez ce message
c'est un nouveau départ pour vous vous
avez tellement de choses à rattraper je
suis si heureuse
depuis ce jour là les deux frères ne se
quittent plus
c'est là 302e famille réunie par cette
idée toute simple
un message un réseau de bénévoles et au
bout un miracle
[Musique]